Narrator: We celebrate
the risk‐takers...
Why not quit the job
and go for it?
...the idea‐makers...
We can really change
the world together.
[ Screams ]
Narrator: ...the ones who
determine their own fate.
‐Whoo!
‐We got a deal!
Narrator:
We celebrate entrepreneurs.
I want y'all to think ‐‐
Who's next?
Narrator:
This is "Shark Tank."
And tonight, Rohan Oza,
the branding guru
behind some of the world's most
successful consumer products,
joins the Tank.
The key to this game is buzz
building and distribution ‐‐
two areas
that I can bring to bear
better
than anybody else here.
Healthy food
is a human right.
You're coming across
as so scattered.
‐And what are your total sales?
‐$1,000.
We're at a crossroads here.
There's a real demand
for this.
‐I'm gonna make you an offer.
‐Whoo!
Robert has to give you that
deal because he doesn't have
the distribution network
to help you.
Rohan,
you just pissed me off.
Who's ready
to make a smokin' deal?
You'd be really annoying
to work with.
‐I'm not annoying.
‐I find you a little annoying.
But I'm still here!
♪♪
Narrator:
First into the Tank
is a beverage made
from an unlikely substance.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Chas Smith.
And my name
is Nikita Salmon.
And we're cousins
from Vermont
and co‐founders of SAP!
We're here today
asking for $600,000
in exchange
for 12% of our business.
Growing up
in the woods of Vermont,
it's impossible to ignore the
beautiful maple and birch trees.
And sap...
is the lifeblood
of these trees.
Their roots pull nutrient‐rich
groundwater from the soil,
which combines with
the sugar stored in the trees
to form this complex
substance, known as sap,
which helps these trees
to grow.
Sap naturally contains
antioxidants, electrolytes,
and over
40 other nutrients,
like B vitamins, iron,
and manganese.
These trees greatly benefit
from their sap,
so why can't we?
That's why we created SAP!,
a healthy beverage company
sourced straight from nature.
And this sap is sourced
from our family farm
and our network
of Vermont producers.
We want to keep
to our roots
and grow the next great
beverage brand
that can help people live
a long and healthy life.
So, Sharks, who wants to get in
on this untapped business?
‐Let's try some SAP!
‐Let's do it.
Let's not be a sap, right?
Don't be a sap.
Try a SAP!
SAP!
‐So, you just grab...
‐The whole thing's for me?
‐Uh, the three.
‐All three?
Any particular order
I'm drinking this in?
‐You know what, Bob? Yeah.
‐Yeah, we do the seltzer,
‐then the soda, then the birch.
‐Okay. Thank you.
So, we recommend trying
the green one first.
What's this one?
So, the first product
is our maple sap seltzer.
So, this is pure maple sap
sourced right
from the maple trees.
‐That tastes really good.
‐Thanks.
It's almost sort of
like cotton candy.
It's smooth.
I mean, it's not a lot
of calories, either,
for what you get.
‐Yeah, so, this ‐‐
‐How many calories?
‐40.
This first product
is supposed to really be
more of a sparkling‐water‐type
experience.
Then the maple sap soda...
This one?
Yeah. So, same single
ingredient ‐‐ maple sap ‐‐
but what we do is, we remove
more water from the sap
to sweeten it up to create more
of a soda‐like experience.
I like this one.
That one mixes fantastic
with bourbon, as well.
Wow! That's like, um,
drinking Aunt Jemima's.
So, the third product
is birch sap.
You know what's interesting?
That's sweet, yeah.
They're all different.
Ohh!
But they're really good.
‐Very different.
‐Robert, was that a good
or a bad "Ohh"?
‐You don't like that?
‐Bad. That's a bad.
‐But Robert doesn't like sweet.
‐It's an acquired taste, but...
‐No, no, no. Try the yellow one.
‐The last one. The yellow one...
‐I am. I'm ‐‐ I like the yellow.
‐Oh.
‐Yes.
‐So, this is still for humans?
‐Yeah.
That tastes like medicine,
for God's sake.
‐Yeah.
‐Yeah, it's more of a ‐‐
‐It's more of a ‐‐
‐Ohh!
‐Wow.
‐You don't like it, either?
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Oh, my God.
To be fair,
the first two are great.
‐Ohh!
‐The sec‐‐
The third's a tad nasty.
‐Take it behind a barn
and shoot it.
‐I don't think ‐‐
I don't think
the third one's bad.
I wouldn't serve this
to Barbara.
So, let me tell you about
the birch a little bit.
It hasn't really come to the
United States yet, because...
Obviously.
Yeah, because it doesn't
make a great syrup
like maple, but it has
a lot more nutrients
and health benefits, so it's
very good for your overall ‐‐
I could see this
curing a hangover.
Like, a really bad hangover.
Yeah, it's a great ‐‐
It's a great hangover cure.
And what's the price today?
What are your sales?
We've only been in business
about 15 months
with these products, and the
birch is even newer than that.
$1.99 per can and
about $7.99 for a four‐pack.
So, Chas, what's your cost?
Blended across
the three products,
about 50 cents right now.
‐50 cents? That's expensive.
‐Okay.
And what are
your total sales?
Total sales to date
are about $400,000.
We're seeing an explosion,
especially around
sparkling water right now.
But in that category,
there's really not a lot
of health attributes
to a normal seltzer
or a normal sparkling water.
It's really
just demineralized water
with some natural flavor
added to it.
Can you explain why this would
be healthy for someone to drink,
versus
just a plain sparkling water?
So, maple naturally
has 46 vitamins,
minerals, and nutrients.
Birch actually has
a little bit more than that.
These are some of the most
nutrient‐rich waters on earth.
How did you get the idea
to make soda
when you're making
maple syrup?
And does
Nikita actually speak?
Yes.
[ Laughter ]
You know, growing up,
you know,
I was in‐‐ involved
in the industry.
My parents' main source
of income is maple syrup.
When I was 19,
I got into the business,
and I purchased the farm
from them when I was 20, so...
Wow.
I have 12,000 taps,
which is kind of a ‐‐
a mid‐size operation in Vermont.
Wow.
About 300 acres.
I had, you know,
5,000‐gallon tanks
of maple sap sitting there,
and we were, you know, fooling
around with the carbonation,
mixing it with bourbon, maybe,
here and there.
And that's where the best
ideas came from, right?
That's where ‐‐ Absolutely.
Where does the water
come from?
Are you literally
tapping the tree?
We tap a very small hole,
following, you know, organic
standard tapping methods
so that we don't damage
the trees.
So, you can see here
some taps going into the trees.
So, in the spring,
the trees naturally flow sap
to ‐‐ to leaf out, and then
we're taking that raw product
and then carbonating
and canning,
so you're getting
the raw product ‐‐
So, you're adding
the carbonation and the water?
There's actually no water
in these products.
This is the liquid
that comes out of the trees.
‐That's pretty cool.
‐Seriously?
‐Yeah.
‐You're adding no water?
‐Right here?
‐No water. No.
You should say that
on the can.
‐Yep.
‐So, look.
I‐I‐I understand beverages
a little bit.
If you guys are coming out
at $1.99, which is doable,
many brands do that,
what is that one or two things
that you have that go,
"Guys, we do this well"?
So, the maple products
have prebiotics in them,
so they're good
for your gut health,
properties that help reduce
inflammation in the body
so that ‐‐
I'm still struggling as
to the why I'm making the
leap...
Mm‐hmm.
...from a regular soda
at 79 cents or 99 cents...
Yep.
...to double that
on SAP! Made in Trees.
This is
a multi‐use beverage,
so it's ‐‐ it's a product
that the entire family can use,
and it's the next level above
the traditional seltzer
in a nutrition sense.
Give it to us in one line.
‐Yeah.
‐One line.
Basically, I would say this ‐‐
It protects your body.
How does it help
with inflammation?
Because that's the big
buzzword now, right?
Yep.
Everybody's saying
inflammation causes cancer.
So, how does this stop
inflammation in the body?
Or help lessen it?
It's this complex substance
that has,
you know,
not just 46 nutrients,
but also a lot of kind
of bioactive properties.
And so, you know,
we've actually been working
with University of Vermont,
University of Cornell
a little bit
to study these properties
a little bit more.
We're helping to try
to bring new research
out there right now.
Do you not really
have that yet?
Are you doing testing
that says maybe we'll be able
to prove this?
Some ‐‐
Yeah, there's some research
out there, absolutely.
I think our top customer
is probably a mom
buying for her family
who has a slightly
higher willingness to pay.
She's wanting to buy it
for her kids
because it's a much better
option than a traditional soda.
Her husband's
probably not gonna use it.
Your story's too long, Chas.
No, I totally get that.
Yeah, I get it, too.
Yeah.
‐It's just that sugar can ‐‐
‐But it's too long.
The product, other than
the one, aren't bad, right?
And I could see giving it my
kids as an alternative to soda
when they have a sweet tooth
and ‐‐ and feel good about it.
So I see what you're
trying to accomplish,
but your marketing sucks.
You've got to simplify this
in a way that's just obvious.
I don't see
that you're there yet.
I'm out.
Ah, fair enough.
All the claims you made,
and probably spent 1/3
of your time here today
explaining why it's good
for your health,
et cetera, et cetera ‐‐
None of it's really conveyed
by the name, the tag line,
or anything.
But then, after that,
I don't like the way it tastes.
For those reasons, I'm out.
So, I liked all three,
and the funniest thing to me
of it all is,
I don't like maple syrup.
I really love
the health thing,
but you're early
for that testing.
My heart wanted to be in
so bad.
I'm sorry.
I'm out.
That's all right.
Thank you.
I don't have an issue
with any of it.
I loved when you came out,
"SAP! Protect your body."
You're the real deal,
but you need somebody
to drive that message.
So I'm gonna make you
an offer.
‐Oh!
‐Whoo!
I'll offer you the $600,000
for 30%.
Cuban: Ooh.
Ooh.
‐Ooh.
Oza: Ooh.
You see how they are
just running to say yes?
They haven't said no, Mark.
Yeah, absolutely.
Rohan?
Look, guys,
it's very tough to start
and get
a beverage business going.
So I want to give you
some credit on that.
My struggle is, you can't
get me a why quickly enough
so that when I have
the 5 seconds on the shelf,
I'm gonna reach in
and grab it.
And I feel
that the functional benefit
to justify a $2.00 price point
to me doesn't exist.
And so, for that reason,
unfortunately, I'm out.
Fair enough.
Wow.
I should change my offer.
You just talked me out of it,
Rohan.
Yeah, and I just want
to kind of follow up
on a couple of those points.
‐No!
‐No, he's out. Don't bother.
‐No.
‐Okay.
‐It's over. It's done.
‐All right.
You might say something
Robert doesn't want to hear.
You have an offer from a ‐‐
from a great Shark.
So, guys, you can counter.
What do you want to do?
♪♪
$600,000 for 20%.
That's a very expensive
flannel shirt.
Eight seasons ago,
when I didn't know
how much work was involved
in getting these businesses
off the ground,
I probably would have done it
just because I‐I like you guys
and I believe in you.
Uh...
That was the offer
I felt comfortable with.
I'm out.
‐Fair enough.
‐Sorry, guys.
‐Good luck. Congratulations.
‐Good luck.
‐Appreciate it.
Cuban: Congrats, man.
♪♪
I don't think we're gonna regret
not taking Robert's offer.
We have amazing belief
in our products.
We've seen tens of thousands
of people try these.
and we think
the valuation was fair.
So we ‐‐ We'll find
the right set of investors
for us going forward.
Robert was in
till I laid my argument out.
The longer you talked, the more
I'm like, "What am I doing?"
"What am I doing?"
You just wanted
to be a lumberjack.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a convenient way
to bring the campfire with you.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Brent.
And I'm Bryan.
And we are fired up
to show you our new product.
Fired up.
We're seeking $50,000
for a 20% stake
in our business.
Campfires have been
a crucial part of men's life
since the beginning of time.
Yes, but campfires
are difficult
to start, maintain,
clean up,
and let's be honest ‐‐
Stumbling around
in the middle of the night
looking for wood is never easy.
But we solved that problem.
Check this out.
♪♪
Whoa! It's fire!
‐Sharks...
‐Now, that's a fire!
...meet the Radiate
Portable Campfire,
the most convenient way
to make a campfire.
Radiate is easy to light,
it's easy to store,
it's easy to carry,
and it leaves no trace.
Take it to the beach,
tailgating, camping.
Even use it
in your own backyard.
It gives off heat, light,
and the urge to sing
campfire songs.
Yeah, but if Robert is gonna
start singing, or Mark,
and we want to end
the campfire quick,
slide the lid back on.
Ah.
‐Cool.
‐Mm‐hmm. I like it.
So, Sharks, who's ready
to make a smokin' deal?
‐"Smokin'." Can we see it?
‐Can we get samples?
‐Absolutely.
‐Great puns.
We'll hand out
some samples to you.
Herjavec: Yeah.
‐Great puns.
‐Perfect.
Greiner: Is there
a difference between the tins,
like scents or anything?
‐Scents.
‐There. Absolutely.
‐Absolutely there is.
I like that.
Give me a good scent.
You're all getting
the original.
‐Thank you so much.
‐Wow.
‐You're welcome.
‐Do you have a lighter, too?
‐Whoa, that's heavy.
‐Yeah. You want to light it up?
‐Oh, it's wax.
‐Just on the side?
Directly on the briquettes.
Oh, you just got
to hold it for a little bit.
‐There you go.
‐Yeah.
Oh, cool!
‐Hit a couple of them.
‐This is ‐‐ Oh, there we go.
Oh, wow!
It's really cool.
What do you make it for?
$5.75.
Wholesale's $12.50.
It retails $25.00.
And how do you sell it?
How many hours does this burn?
So, this will burn
for up to six hours.
Just six?
How much does ‐‐
How much does this weigh?
‐Just six. It's a 4‐pound unit.
‐4 pounds, Mark.
‐4 pounds?
‐Yeah.
‐Does this create ship‐‐
‐So, then...
...shipping problems,
the fact that it's so heavy?
Sure.
So, it costs about $9.50
to ship it in the U. S.
for one,
but it only costs
about $13.00 to ship two.
I want to go back
to the burn time...
‐Yeah.
‐Sure.
...because it's $25.00,
but you only get
six hours' burn time.
‐Only?
‐Six hours is a long time.
‐So, okay...
‐Yeah. That's...
That's not that long.
Our InstaFire
burns indefinitely.
‐Lori.
‐That's not that long.
So, how does this compare
to InstaFire,
a deal
that Lori and I did?
InstaFire is meant to,
you know,
make a traditional type
of campfire,
either in a fireplace
or a...
But I could just buy ‐‐ I‐I
could just bring a tin with ‐‐
from my cookies, right?
InstaFire is a ‐‐
an awesome product.
There's no question
about that.
This is built for families,
okay?
If you want to have a campfire
in your backyard,
you take this out,
and you throw it up.
Why couldn't I just take a tin
and put a couple InstaFires in
to save ‐‐ save some money
and accomplish the same thing?
It's convenient.
Convenience is
a bigger factor.
Real outdoors people
use InstaFire, okay?
This is a product
for a lot of people
that don't necessarily want to
be outdoors for days at a time.
Break down the numbers
for me.
We've been shipping
for 30 days, Rohan.
We sold 1,100 units.
Oh, wow.
We crowdfunded 400 units.
Okay, how much?
What was your goal?
$1,000. We were trying
to get a proof of concept.
We've done 6‐‐ 6‐‐
Greiner: So, you've only been
in business,
essentially, for 30 days?
That's correct.
And it was
a crowdfunding campaign?
No, no.
Just wait a sec.
Once we got
the concept proved
and people
were interested in it,
we've sold 600 through
traditional wholesale retail.
Where?
What kind of retail?
Surf shops, camp stores...
Tell 'em the Kauai story.
...sporting‐goods stores.
My wife and I
were on vacation.
Even before we were shipping,
I had samples of it,
We went to Kauai,
and we were using it,
taking pictures of it,
and people were coming up
and saying, "Oh, my God,
where'd you get that?
Where'd you get that?"
But ‐‐ But I wanted
to ask you that.
Okay, wait. Before you ‐‐
Guys. Hey, guys.
We're starting
to get a lot of smoke.
Can you put a lid on it?
Yeah. Pardon?
In areas
where I can't have a fire,
like a beach or a forest...
Sure.
...am I allowed
to light this?
Yeah,
in ‐‐ in most instances,
what you need
is a contained fire, okay?
This is a contained fire,
and so, yeah,
you're allowed to do it.
You can shut it on and off, just
like I‐I‐I demonstrated here.
So you can have a campfire
and literally get up and leave,
and no one knows
you were there.
What are the other scents?
Is that
a mosquito‐repelling one?
That's correct.
It has eucalyptus
and lemon oil in it
to repel mosquitoes.
And the last one
is a s'more kit.
And then we have
a ‐‐ a s'more kit.
What about ‐‐ A concern I have
is the heat of the tin.
I don't see any warning
on the tin.
As soon as you open up
the tin,
there's a warning label
and instruction manual inside.
Okay. So, I'm gonna make you
an offer, all right?
I'll give you $50,000
for 25%.
Thank you so much
for the offer.
But this ‐‐
Well, you're not gonna
just say thank you...
Oh, okay.
...because I'd really like
to have an answer.
Okay. Great.
Do you want to tell them
the ‐‐ the other sales point?
Yeah, let me ‐‐ There's ‐‐
Is this coming to a yes
or a no ‐‐ the sales point?
Absolutely.
Okay.
But there is ‐‐
We just need to educate you
one more th‐‐
about one more feature.
‐There is one more feature.
She just made you an offer.
What else
do you need to educate her on?
We want her to know
what she's getting into, Mark.
Bryan: We ‐‐
‐Come on.
‐Well, that's what you do
after you do the deal.
‐Brent, is it ‐‐
Is it selling time,
or is it closing time?
Right?
‐Let me say something, Brent.
‐Sure.
There's a piece of me
that is saying
you'd be really annoying
to work with.
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in.
Brent and Bryan have one offer
on the table from Barbara
for their campfire‐in‐a‐tin
product, Radiate.
However, Brent's personality
may jeopardize the deal.
There's a piece of me
that is saying
you'd be really annoying
to work with.
So don't prove me right
on that instinct.
Guys, I'm gonna make it easy
for Barbara.
I think
the product's too heavy.
I don't think
it's original enough.
I think
it's a little bit too expensive.
I just am not
all that excited about it.
And so for those reasons,
I'm out.
Okay.
Thanks, Mark.
I'm gonna make it easier, too.
I like the concept.
Mark and I did InstaFire
and it ‐‐
It's a great product.
‐Which is a great product.
InstaFire burns indefinitely,
and it's safe,
all‐natural, and nontoxic.
This burns
for only six hours.
So I'm sorry.
I'm out.
Thanks, Lori.
I'm sorry to hear that.
Rohan,
what are you gonna do?
Well, they haven't given
Barbara a response yet,
so, I mean, you know...
Well, I think they're waiting
to see what you're gonna do.
Really? Are you guys ‐‐
Are you out or not?
I'm waiting to see
what you're gonna do.
I'd like them
to respond to Barbara.
I mean, I feel like
she ‐‐ You know, they
got to respect that.
‐Barbara, I think that ‐‐
‐No, no.
He has an ulterior motive.
I'm surprised
Barbara's still in.
He wants you to respond
to me...
He's not being nice.
...so he can give you
a worse deal.
You know, Barbara,
I want to work with you.
And ‐‐ And ‐‐ And ‐‐
And I don't take it personally
that you think I'm annoying,
because, honestly,
I'm not annoying.
‐You've heard it before?
I just ‐‐ I do what I do,
and I get things done.
So I‐I don't
find that annoying.
I just fi‐‐ I find it honest.
Like,
I'll tell you what I feel,
and I hope you tell me,
you know, how you feel.
I find you a little annoying.
That's fine.
That's fine. That's fine.
But, at the end of the day,
if we're working together...
Yeah.
...and you need me
to go out and pitch somebody,
you're gonna want me
to know all the information
before I make a deal.
Brent, honestly,
I have total confidence in you
as an entrepreneur.
You have that fire in your belly
that I'm always looking for.
All my great entrepreneurs
are annoying in one way.
When I used to manage
salespeople,
I always knew who were
gonna be the best ones
because they drove me nuts,
okay?
I don't object to that.
Oza: I actually like
your engaging personality.
I like the fact
that you've got ‐‐
You've intimidated
the crap out of Robert.
He hasn't said anything,
sitting in the corner there.
Robert, you're a Boy Scout.
You've been a Boy Scout.
I was a Queen Scout.
I actually like ‐‐
I like what you have to offer.
There you go.
That didn't come out right.
‐A Queen Scout?
‐That didn't come out right.
‐Wait just...
‐What's a Queen Scout?
‐Do you want to define that?
‐Really?
In Canada,
the top scout you could be...
Got to be for queen.
Anybody...
...would be a Queen Scout,
so it was like an Eagle Scout.
I just wanted to define that.
Anyway, go ahead, Rohan.
Anyway, so...
‐Oh, boy.
‐...I‐I think
I have a larger network...
Okay.
...than Barbara has.
I feel that the products
that I have
go with a lot
of those areas.
So I'll also offer you
$50,000 for 25%.
And if I could just
add something else...
I have no doubt in my mind
that this is a winner.
The portability of this,
the size of it,
the weight of it,
you could stack it,
it's easy to show in an aisle,
you don't need an end cap.
This is a phenomenal product.
‐Thank you, Barbara.
It's a moneymaker, honey.
I don't see it just in
camping goods or sporting goods.
I see it in gift shops.
I mean, you've done
an amazing job with this.
[ Cuban laughs ]
‐Oh, boy. Here we go.
‐Mark ‐‐ Mark laughs.
But I have this
in several clothing boutiques
that have been selling it
and reordering.
‐Yeah, of course.
‐Absolutely.
People pay for convenience.
People pay for cool.
I don't find you annoying.
So, Robert,
is there an offer there?
I find you ‐‐
Robert, make your offer.
I find you quirky.
I'll also offer you $50,000
for 25%.
♪♪
So, the key to this game is buzz
building and distribution...
Right.
...two areas
that I can bring to bear
better than
anybody else here.
You just need
a few key connections
and some great ideas,
and you guys have the energy
to punch this through.
Rohan's a great guy.
I'm sure he can invite you
to the best parties,
and you can hang out.
It's a business.
Robert has to give you that
deal because he doesn't have
the distribution network
to help you.
That's ‐‐ This is ‐‐
This is ridiculous.
Now you're just
pissing me off.
I‐I hate to lose, and I want
to invest with you guys
and win with you guys.
I'll give you the $100,000
for 25%.
I've doubled my amount.
I'm tired of this.
This product
is gonna be huge.
$100,000 for 25%.
He's a Queen Scout.
No one
messes with the Queen Scout!
Robert, you have the passion
for the business.
Right.
We'd like to make
a deal with you.
Done.
Yeah!
The Queen Scout
comes on board.
‐Oh!
‐The new...
Barbara,
there was not even like,
"Would you like to counter?"
‐Bam!
Congratulations, guys.
I would have gone up.
‐Thank you so much.
‐Oh, please.
‐Oh.
‐High five, buddy.
That's how it's done.
Oh, that was amazing.
Chum the waters
a little bit.
Whew!
We went with Robert because
he gave us the best offer.
He was the one that was
passionate about the product,
and he made it known
with his offer.
It was easy to tell
he was the right choice.
‐Now there's Queen Scout Robert!
‐Yes!
‐Now there's Queen Robert.
‐Now there's Queen Scout Robert.
‐I like it. Good job, buddy.
‐Come on.
Come on! Come on!
‐Get out of here.
Get out of here.
‐Come on!
I ‐‐ I‐I'll give it to you.
I'll give it to you.
Rohan, at a certain point,
you just pissed me off.
No, I respect it.
Desperate.
That's what I say ‐‐
desperate.
That was annoying to me.
You're annoying.
‐Rohan ‐‐
‐You're annoying.
‐Rohan...
‐You're annoying!
♪♪
Narrator: Just months ago,
Robbie Cabral surprised everyone
by making a deal
with Kevin O'Leary
for his fingerprint‐sensor
padlock, BenjiLock.
For some reason,
my heart is telling me
to go with Mr. Wonderful.
‐What?!
‐What?
‐Oh, wow!
Narrator: Let's see
what he's doing now.
Man: The founder and C. E. O.
of BenjiLock, Robbie Cabral,
is with us today.
Cabral: My gut told me
to go with Kevin,
and I could not be happier
because he keeps delivering.
Kevin brought me
to an interview at CNBC.
I thought I was just going to
talk about my product with him,
and all of a sudden,
he surprised me
with a licensing deal.
Hampton is really excited
about this partnership.
It's my pleasure
to present you with this check.
The licensing deal
is for $450,000.
Hampton products
will distribute BenjiLock
all over North America.
Being unemployed
for three or so years
and all of a sudden,
I'm gonna be able to not only
provide for my family, but also
secure jobs for other people,
it's incredible.
O'Leary: I've been coming
to this show my whole life.
This is the hardest job there is
against all the other
competition.
Mm‐hmm.
CES is the nexus
of new development
in consumer electronics,
and it's exactly
where Robbie needs to be
because he's got
to sell the product now.
Having the right partner
like Hampton,
who's been a supplier of Ace
for 23 years,
it makes us be able
to proceed with confidence.
So Ace Hardware would like
to place an order
for $1.5 million
worth of product.
O'Leary: I told Robbie
on "Shark Tank" only 90 days ago
I'd make him rich.
You're watching it happen
right now.
You know what I say to all
my other fellow sharks?
When it comes time
to do great deals,
let Mr. Wonderful
show you how to do it.
Learn from me, grasshoppers.
Learn.
Teamwork makes
the dream work.
He came to America,
and he got laid off.
But he didn't let it stop him.
He always saw the future
as something bright
even though he was living
in the darkness.
He made his own
American dream happen.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a beverage
targeted to a unique market.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Julie from
Cornelius, North Carolina.
And I'm Ryan
from Gahanna, Ohio.
And we are here seeking
a $150,000 investment
for a 20% stake
in our company.
Sharks...
♪♪
Julie.
Cuban: It's okay.
It's only the most important
day in your life.
Corcoran:
You got our name right.
I know, I know,
and you're right in the middle.
It freaks everybody out.
Yes, yes, yes.
And there's a new set!
‐Go again.
‐Sharks.
Sharks...
Herjavec: Sharks.
...as humans, we have
all kinds of drink options
and ways to treat ourselves
throughout the day,
but our dogs, they only
ever have plain water.
How boring!
Right?
Boring.
All day, every day.
And while they see us
sipping on our sports drinks
and our lattes,
Fido gets...
plain old water.
‐Wah‐wah‐wah.
‐No, not anymore.
Let us introduce you
to Petrol Fuel for Dogs.
Petrol is a delicious,
hydrating,
vitamin‐enhanced water
for dogs.
It's made of 100%
all‐natural flavorings,
plus six added vitamins
and minerals
that are good for dogs'
overall health.
And dogs love it.
But, Sharks, you don't have
to just take our word for it.
We brought along today
one of our most
loyal customers...
We sure did.
...and her award‐winning
agility dog to show you.
Corcoran: Here she comes. Wow.
Diane...
‐[ Laughs ]
‐...and Rrrrrrrocco!
‐Rocco!
‐Aww.
‐Good one.
‐Is that a shih tzu?
‐Yeah.
What an athlete!
Rocco!
Feed me.
Feed me now.
Aww.
Now, is Rocco thirsty,
or is the product that good?
Dogs lap it up
4 to 1 over regular water.
‐Wow!
‐Oh, wow!
[ Laughter ]
Herjavec: That is so cute!
Great job, guys.
Cuban: Good job. Thank you.
Julie:
Thank you, Diane and Rocco.
Can we, like, taste it?
Absolutely you can taste it.
Is it fine for humans, too?
We've certainly tasted it.
Oza:
Is it flavored?
It's n‐‐ It has
all‐natural flavors in it.
So, sweeter?
Uh, savory.
Savory!
That's never a good sign.
I'll just grab one?
Okay.
So, all‐natural flavors.
There's a B‐complex, biotin,
niacin, and L‐carnitine.
Cute picture.
Thank you.
Great logo.
Ohh.
[ Chuckling ]
Oh, my God.
Make her drink it
from a bowl.
Cuban:
What's it taste like?
Totally not what I expected.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
It tastes like bone broth.
Yes.
Corcoran: Ew!
[ Laughing ] Oh!
It smells like bone broth.
Julie: I mean, it is
a dog product, right?
Well, dogs like bones.
It is a dog product.
So, Julie, I got to ask...
Yes.
...why?
I love dogs.
Sure.
I know you do.
What's wrong with water?
Well, you know,
I want our dogs to enjoy
the variety of beverages
that we do, as well.
So, I found a veterinary
nutritionist to formulate it.
We worked on several different
flavor profiles, Lori,
and this one was the winner
out of all of them.
That would make sense.
What are you guys selling
at the moment?
What's the revenue,
and where are you selling
at the moment?
We did a crowdfunding campaign
a year ago,
and what that
allowed us to do,
and I'm ‐‐ I'm gonna come back
to how we started,
and we had to take a break
and why ‐‐ why we're back. Um...
Oh, you ‐‐ you shut
the company down for a while?
I shel‐‐ I shelved the company
for a little bit, so when you ‐‐
Corcoran:
What's a little bit?
How many years ago
did you start?
Sure.
So, I honestly started
this journey, if you will,
about 10 years ago.
10?
2010, we went
to the largest trade show,
and we were overwhelmed
with the response that we got.
Did you ‐‐ Did you have sales
during that time?
We had o‐over a dozen companies
asking us to export the product.
We had no idea
how to do that.
We had no idea what
a container of product would be.
And so, we went to go to get
a small‐business loan.
Everybody knows
what was going on in 2010.
There were
no small‐business loans,
certainly not for a female
business owner at that time.
And so, we had to shelve it.
And you've decided
to bring this back to life.
When did that happen,
when you kicked it up again
to get it going?
So, honestly, it was ‐‐
it was about 18 months ago.
So, it's a new company,
effectively.
‐So, here you are.
‐Correct. It's a new company.
Oza: Talk to me
about the new company.
That's what I care about.
Cuban: So, you started ‐‐
you started again...
Yes.
...18 months ago.
Correct.
I brought Ryan
on board.
Ryan,
did you put money in it?
I'm a principal
in the business.
How much?
Yeah, I‐I put in $25,000.
So what are your sales
for the last 18 months?
Go ahead.
Corcoran: Your sales.
Sales for the last 16 months
were $16,000.
♪♪
Wow.
That's not great news.
Julie: We don't ‐‐ We're ‐‐
We're out of product.
So, we literally
don't have product,
which is why
we're here today.
We're at a crossroads here.
Why haven't you sold
anything else, unless...
We're out of product.
Wait. Okay, guys,
none of this is adding up.
Okay, here's the timeline
as I see it...
Oza: Let's back it up.
Yes.
...and why I have a problem.
First of all, you go
to a trade show 10 years ago.
Correct.
What happened
that allowed you
to fund it then?
I sold part of my 401(k).
‐Oh.
‐So, how much money
did you put in yourself
from your 401(k)?
$100,000.
Wow.
That's ‐‐
Something's wrong there.
Out of that $100,000,
you didn't think
to save money for product
so you can deliver on orders?
Well, honestly, Mark,
at the time,
I really thought that
as a woman‐owned business,
I would be able
to get funding.
We're talking green.
We're not talking
woman‐owned business,
man‐owned business,
Martian‐owned business.
Mm‐hmm.
We're talking common sense.
Right?
How much of the $100,000 did
you spend on the trade show?
Um, we spent about $10,000.
Uh, the trade ‐‐
Then where did
the other $90,000 go?
What happened to the other
$90,000, Julie?
Th‐The other $90,000 went
to the research,
the product run
cost a lot of money.
You had product,
so why didn't you sell that?
Sure.
We ‐‐ We sold the product.
And then we gave,
as you know,
we had to do
a lot of product sampling.
Then we ‐‐ we were done.
Like, I didn't have
any more money.
Guys, look, you're coming across
as so scattered.
♪♪
You used no business sense
whatsoever
in your first go‐around,
then you come back into it,
and you put in $25,000
on round two, correct?
We didn't want a slow drip
into the market.
We believe it's a race
to this space.
We're trying to leverage
the wind at our back
in functional beverage.
Your‐‐ Your entire assumption
was, "It's a race to the space."
‐To create a new category.
‐It's a ‐‐ It's a one‐man race.
You had $25,000.
How can you create a category?
Oza:
And ‐‐ And you're racing ‐‐
That's why we're here.
‐Has it ‐‐
‐If this is proved
out of one market or even
with one lead customer,
I would say, "Got it,
there's a real demand for this."
Yes.
But my fear is that
the necessity for vitamins
in the pet food space...
Yes.
...is being delivered
through enhanced food.
Yes.
And therefore,
I'm not sure
if there's a real
consumer demand
for a vitamin‐enhanced beverage
and paying out for that.
And for that reason,
I'm out.
Oh ‐‐ Oh, my gosh.
♪♪
Julie, I'm always suspect of any
business that starts and stops.
Okay.
Because any business
I've ever seen that succeeded
started and kept going ‐‐
somehow kept going.
So, for that reason,
I'm out.
I'm really sorry
to hear that.
I don't know
if dogs need this or not.
Is this something
people need and want?
Yes.
Is it something
they're going to buy?
‐Yes.
‐I'm not sure.
And for those reasons,
I'm out.
Oh, Lori,
I'm really sad to...
I'm sorry.
♪♪
Herjavec:
My challenge is with you.
I've heard from you
it was the economy.
"I couldn't get funding because
I was a woman‐owned business."
I heard a lot of externalized
challenges, and that is ‐‐
But I'm still here.
And ‐‐ And ‐‐ And ‐‐
And I ‐‐ And I won't give up.
I hear you, and I admire people
that have a go‐get‐it attitude.
I just temper that
against the 10 years
that it took you to get here.
But we took a break.
Okay. It's ‐‐
It's what I heard today.
That made me uncomfortable.
I'm out.
Robert, I'm s‐‐ As a dog lover,
I'm sorry to hear that.
Guys, like, we need your
expertise. We need your help.
You have to figure
how to get from where you are
with $25,000 in the bank
to a point
where you are self‐sustaining.
Ryan: Sure.
And you didn't do that.
That's why we're here.
You're here t‐‐
You ‐‐ You can't.
You're looking
for us to save you.
Cuban:
You're betting your whole ‐‐
No, I'm not looking
for you to sa‐‐
Yes.
How else would you do it?
What are you gonna do
if you don't get paid?
"A" ‐‐ sales cures all.
Right?
If you don't have sales,
you don't have a business.
"B" ‐‐ you have to anticipate
how you're gonna use your cash
to get to a point
of profitability.
You can't assume
you're gonna be able to get
a woman‐owned business loan.
You can't assume that coming
here is gonna bail you out.
You have to plan,
knowing that this
is the only cash that you have.
You didn't do it the first time.
You're in the process
of not doing it the second time.
I don't see how anything
is gonna change going forward.
So, for those reasons, I'm out.
Good luck, guys.
Thank you.
‐Thank you, guys.
‐Sorry, you guys.
Th‐This isn't the ‐‐ the last
of us that you'll see.
‐I hope you guys ‐‐
‐We wish you the best.
You know,
I tell my kids all the time ‐‐
We wish you the best.
I hope you crush it.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
Greiner: Good luck.
Robert,
as a dog lover...
‐Thanks, guys.
‐One last chance.
Thank you.
Barbara, one of five kids,
grew up in a similar...
[ Lori chuckles ]
Oh, you guys. Sorry.
...environment like you did.
Cuban: Sorry, guys.
Thank you.
While this is another setback,
this is not the end
by any means.
Hopefully,
we'll see it on shelves
everywhere where there's
a human beverage soon.
We'll get 'em.
All right?
We got 'em.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up
is a company whose mission
is to bring healthy food
to all communities.
♪♪
Hi.
I'm Sam Polk.
And I'm David Foster.
We're from
Los Angeles, California.
And we are the founders
of Everytable.
We are thrilled
to be here tonight,
and we're seeking investment
of $1 million
in exchange for 5%
of our company.
Whoo!
[ Chuckles ]
Everytable is a healthy,
grab‐and‐go concept
that's revolutionizing
the restaurant industry
and making healthy food
affordable for everyone.
Demand for healthy food
is exploding,
but the truth is,
when salads cost $15
and green juices cost $9,
healthy food has become
a luxury that few can afford.
Even worse,
there are some neighborhoods
called food deserts
that have absolutely no access
to healthy food at all.
At Everytable, we believe
that healthy food
is a human right.
And here is how we are
making that a reality.
Every morning
at our central kitchen,
our world‐class chefs
prepare incredibly fresh,
healthy, and, importantly,
delicious meals.
Things like
a kale chicken Caesar salad,
vegan miso grain bowls,
and an out‐of‐this‐world
Jamaican jerk chicken
with coconut, beans and rice,
and plantains,
which are then packaged
and sent to our restaurants.
Centralized production
results
in incredible efficiencies
in the kitchen
and makes our locations
significantly cheaper
to build and operate.
We opened stores
in affluent communities
and food‐desert
communities.
And to make sure that our food
is affordable for everyone,
we vary the prices based on what
that neighborhood can afford.
We're on a mission
to make good food
available for everyone.
So, help us put
an Everytable
in every community
all across America.
You want to try some food?
Greiner: Yes.
‐Sure.
‐Why not?
‐Yeah.
‐Yeah, let's do it.
May I try
that jerk chicken, please?
‐That's yours, actually.
‐Yes.
Is it jerk chicken and miso?
Foster: Barbara, you've got
the Jamaican jerk chicken
for you.
Ladies first.
This is for you,
a kale chicken Caesar salad.
For you,
Puebla chicken tinga.
And, Robert...
Thank you.
...ensalada fresca
with chicken for you.
Thank you.
So, you've got
the dressing in there,
cheese if you'd like it.
‐Great.
‐Food tastes fantastic.
Greiner: Yeah.
Oza: By the way, I'm very much
bought in to your guys'
philosophy.
If you are lower income,
your access to better foods
gets reduced,
and you're stuck
with the bad products
because they're cheap.
So, I love the way
you're varying the pricing on,
you know,
if you can afford more,
you pay more, and if you can't,
you pay less.
Wait, explain that again,
'cause I missed that part.
Yeah, so we have locations
in affluent areas,
like Century City, Santa Monica,
and downtown,
and in those locations,
the stores sell these meals
for $7 or $8.
But we also opened stores
in places like South L. A.,
Baldwin Hills,
and coming soon,
Watts and Compton.
Mmm.
And in those communities,
we sell the same meals,
from the same stores, for exac‐‐
for basically $4 to $5.
And each location is meant
to be profitable,
but just differently
profitable.
So you mentioned food deserts.
What exactly is that?
So, we ‐‐
let me show you up here.
So this is a map
of Los Angeles.
These are all the sort of
affluent communities.
So you have Santa Monica
and Beverly Hills and Pasadena,
and in those locations,
per capita income
can be sometimes
$100,000, $150,000.
In this location,
this is neighborhoods like
South Los Angeles,
Watts, Compton.
You can have per capita income
as low as $13,000 a year.
Wow.
Now, these communities,
they're left out
of a functioning,
healthy food system.
So, for example, folks born
in this zip code right here
will live on average
12 years less
than folks born in this,
even though
they're 5 miles apart.
Why is there no healthy food
being pumped into those deserts?
If you think
about a fast‐food chain,
they have potatoes,
which last forever,
they have frozen beef,
they have buns
that never go bad,
and they're all
very cheap.
Hmm.
So, you can run a business
that sells those foods at $5.
Makes sense.
If you're running
a healthy‐food business,
you have fresh food,
there's more spoilage,
issues like that,
so it's hard to get
to a price point
that is comparable
to fast food...
I see.
...unless you structure it
from the beginning,
like we have,
to hit that price point.
Oza:
You're coming for $1 million,
which is a big amount.
You're then asking ‐‐
You're only giving up 5%,
which, if my math is correct,
has put you
at a $20 million valuation.
Is that correct?
That's correct.
It's a healthy valuation.
Help me understand
why you think
your company's already worth
$20 million.
Let me just tell you
a little bit about our
fundraising history.
‐Sure.
‐So, we raised a seed round
of $2.9 million
on a convertible note.
‐Of what valuation?
‐A valuation cap at $7 million.
Subsequent to that,
raised $2 million
at a $23.5 million
valuation cap.
In terms of revenue, last year
we opened our first location,
so that's in South L. A.
That one did
about $650,000.
Oh, that's great.
And the way ‐‐ We had
one location last summer.
We now have five.
So all rolled up,
the five locations,
the current run rate
is about $2.6 million.
So, are you burning money
right now?
Yeah, we are.
Our burn rate right now
is about $125,000 a month.
And that's basically
because
we've invested heavily
for growth.
So, what's your typical cost,
um, for a bowl, all in,
overhead?
$2.50 to 3 bucks, all in.
So, even when you're selling
for $5 in the food desert,
you're at a 40% to 50%
gross margin,
60% to 70% when
you're selling
for 8 bucks
in the affluent markets.
Can you share with me
your backgrounds?
I grew up in Los Angeles
and was always
super ambitious.
Went to Columbia and then
went to Wall Street.
And by the time I was 30,
I was a senior trader
at one of the largest
hedge funds in the world.
During the crash
of '08 and '09,
I started to shift
my vision of success.
And so, I left that world
and started a non‐profit
called Groceryships
that helps parents
that are living in food deserts
get themselves
and their families healthy.
And that's ‐‐ David and I met
through the non‐profit.
I love what you did here today.
It's rare that we see someone
present so cleanly,
have all the answers,
keep their cool,
answer every question.
But the whole time,
I'm trying so hard to like it,
and I'm thinking, "What the hell
is bugging me here?"
Somehow, I don't think
you're entrepreneurs.
I don't feel
a fire in your belly.
You can call my wife
and ask her.
No, no, no.
Here's what I want to say.
You're not bringing it
on the table here today.
I'm just gonna trust
my instinct on this.
I wish you luck,
and I admire your mission,
but I'm out.
What you've achieved in one
year, I think it's fantastic.
But, here‐‐ here's
my only challenge.
You know, in business, I like
to follow the poo‐poo principle,
which is poo poo happens,
and the amount of money
that you've raised
and the valuation you have
of $20 million,
there is no room for poo poo.
You basically have built in
flawless execution
from now into the future.
I just know from reality,
poo poo happens.
I'm out.
I love the mission.
It's in sync with everything
that I'm about.
Here's my problem.
It's easy to raise money,
especially from where
you come from.
But what I wanted
to hear today was...
creativity, drive,
fire, and marketing.
But you were missing
that really important component.
So, unfortunately, I'm out.
On one hand,
I was really excited,
because the mission's awesome.
But the crusade part
scares the hell out of me.
$20 million valuation
means you need to generate
$20 million in profits
before I get my money back.
Right?
You're going
to have to go through a lot
of painful lessons first, right?
And I think the valuation,
to Robert's point,
isn't there to go through
the difficult times.
And so, for those reasons,
I'm out.
Oza:
I do like your idea.
My issue is your valuation
should be more in line
with what the market is.
I'll give you the upper end,
which is three times
your run rate, as you call it.
That would put you
at $7.5 million valuation.
We appreciate the offer.
At that level, that‐that's not
super attractive,
and we'd like to find a way to
work with you, but on terms...
Wow.
...that are closer
to our original offer.
The forecast for next year is ‐‐
is $6 million
with just company‐owned stores,
so 3 times 6 is 18.
If you want to invest...
You're asking me to do
a multiple off next year.
Who knows what happens
next year?
I can only look
at what's there today.
It seems to me like
you're gonna have to really
come head to head here
right now.
Because, I mean, y‐you ‐‐
coming off of 18 to 20
is not really ‐‐ it's not worth
a counter, to be honest.
You see where I'm at.
I'm fine if you want to counter
something above what I'm at,
but it's nowhere in the realm
of where you guys are at.
♪♪
Narrator:
Four Sharks are out.
Rohan is interested
in Sam and David's
socially‐conscious healthy food
company, Everytable,
but he has an issue with
their $20‐million valuation.
Coming off of 18 to 20
is not really ‐‐
it's not worth a counter,
to be honest.
You see where I'm at.
I'm fine if you want to counter
something above where I'm at,
but it's nowhere in the realm
of where you guys are at.
The truth is, Rohan, that
from the moment we walked in,
we were hoping
to get a deal with you.
We do think you could bring
a tremendous amount
of value to our brand,
and we'd be thrilled
to work with you.
We had a best and final
that we had pre‐agreed on this.
We are gonna go better
than that,
and this is the best
we can do.
The ‐‐ The best and final
is $1 million on $15 million.
So, okay, this is it, guys.
This is ‐‐ This is ‐‐
This is ‐‐ This is the jam.
This is it. I get up and hug you
or it's peace out.
So, I'm saying, okay, my final,
no messing around,
$1 million
for 10% of the company.
That's it.
Now, it's got to be right now.
♪♪
[ Indistinct conversation ]
What are you gonna do, guys?
I want to work with him.
So, it's 10%.
Imagine running the business
with these guys.
All right, guys, 10 seconds,
you got to make the call.
[ Indistinct conversation ]
Rohan, come on.
Move this puppy along.
All right.
Yeah.
We'll do it.
Whoa!
Thank God!
[ Laughing ] Oh!
All right!
Good job, guys.
Wow.
Hallelujah.
It took a minute
of discussion. Hi.
Hi.
Thank you.
Wow.
Congrats, Ro.
Congrats, guys.
♪♪
Polk: We're so excited
to be partnered with Rohan Oza,
and even more importantly,
we're excited
that we can use
his marketing skills
to bring an Everytable
into every single community
in the country.
I love when they tell you
you're the favorite
after you're the only one.
Cuban: The only one, right.
Yeah. You were obviously
my favorite going in.
Obviously.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪